elle sillonne les routes du tour de
france et ce depuis 1930
la caravane publicitaire impossible de
la rater on la voit arriver de loin très
loin comme ici en 1948 à liège et la
campagne lorraine et en regardant
défiler des motos des cartes
publicitaires et aussi des coureurs à
chaque tour de france elle précède
l'arrivée des coureurs dans les années
70 en guise de cadeau
on distribue des chapeaux les
autocollants et aussi les casquettes
poulidor tout est gratuit et il y en a
vraiment pour tous les goûts
certes les décibels agressifs sont
déversés à longueur de journée on y
ajoute des distributions de prospectus
ou d'échantillons réclamé à grands cris
par les spectateurs vingt ans plus tard
en 1999
la caravane est toujours là mais les
cadeaux change cette fois on y danse du
fromage des sacs et même du saucisson à
l'époque tous ces produits sont
distribués par des femmes les hôtesses
du tour de france est en écoute et cette
jeune femme ça n'a pas l'air d'être un
métier facile finalement moi je regarde
même pas les pères regardent leurs
souliers neufs savoir celles qui ont
l'air d'être agressif très stressé comme
ça non non les têtes je peux pas les
voir en 2003 ce sont plus de 200
véhicules publicitaires qui s'enchaînent
sur la route
au total 11 millions de gadgets en tout
genre sont distribués aux spectateurs
et malgré ce chiffre impressionnant il
n'y en a pas pour tout le monde
les attraper
et puis vont beaucoup là bas les pattes
s'enrichit les spectateurs ne sont pas
les seuls à profiter de la caravane
publicitaire dans le cortège de
véhicules
il ya celui de la gendarmerie oui vous
avez bien entendu en 2004 elle distribue
et non pas des contraventions mais bien
des porte-clés en forme de képis les
gens nous faut la réflexion voit sourire
c'est saab à la jordanie c'est sympa
bonne image en 2020 à cause de la crise
sanitaire
la caravane publicitaire avait été
réduite de moitié cette année
elle fait son grand retour avec 150
véhicules d'une trentaine de marques et
accrochez-vous bien plus de 12 millions
de goodies à distribuer
[Musique]